i'm
almost 30 years old
i have no money i feel
like loser the latest episode of the
other way
gave us emotional breakdown
[Music]
after emotional breakdown
[Music]
i don't know like what the
[ __ ] but it wasn't all messy we also had
kenneth and armando bringing us some
romance
how'd you sleep last night actually
amazing did you
i fell right out oh
you know what that means hey my 90 day
fans fam
it's melisia here don't worry i'll
update you on brittany's temper tantrum
in the car
in just a few but first let's get into
jihoon who turned to his mother
for comfort after his big fight with
devin
he also revealed why he doesn't have any
money
i have no money because i have a debt
thirty thousand dollars so
i'm just borrowing money from parents
[Music]
hong kong
[Music]
i know it's a cultural thing for some
but
i was kind of sad to see jihoon so upset
and then get told by his mom to suck it
up
just like women men's bodies produce
tears for a reason
to cry there was a point in the
conversation where she tried to help
by justifying his lying behavior
which is
if a man likes a woman he will use white
lies
not malicious ones what if
if a man likes a woman he just wouldn't
lie at all
because lying could potentially make you
lose that woman you like so much
what about that wow jihoon's mom kind of
missed the mark on that one
she left him with this piece of sound
advice
you get
that's right mom okay now we gotta talk
about brittany
who had a moment that i've had before
maybe a few times that moment where you
just get so
frustrated that you have to let it out
you didn't tell me that i kept telling
you on the phone my dad can't come till
january
you don't know that no i don't i was
like yeah
i was sad i don't care
i don't know like what the [ __ ]
i don't
literally took both of his hands off of
the wheel to calm
brittany down this was one of my
favorite moments during the episode
because we got to see a different side
of him britney
had a long day she's away from her
family in a foreign country
she just got yelled at by her her
fiance's mom
we stronger we can't bring anything
not only did yazan choose to comfort her
after her tantrum but he also had a nice
romantic spread of roses
waiting for her once she got home you're
going home
are your parents gonna be mad if you
stay yeah
i will say this i've never seen someone
lay roses
in a path towards the bed and not stay
the night
but the gesture was sweet and yazan's
willpower
is on point you nervous
yeah i'm so very very nervous
next week on the other way ariella her
mom and binium
visit an ethiopian hospital as they get
closer
to ariela's due date the artist's mother
she's a nurse
she knows very well i mean has hospital
is associated with america
well hopefully everything checks out all
right 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t to get the
latest updates on our guilty pleasure
mwah see you next time